Speaker 1: We are going to now look at a
Republican primary so absurd, so unhinged,
so disconnected and untethered from reality that
someone who's really pretty nuts politically,
Liz Cheney, looks like the voice of reason
in comparison. And I'm going to explain
that. I'm going to defend that statement. Liz
Cheney is a current House of Representatives
congresswoman representing Wyoming in the U.S.
House of Representatives. She's got quite a
primary. She has become a popular target of Donald
Trump's popular target of the Trumpian right. And
they want to get her out. And Wyoming PBS held
a debate between Liz Cheney and her challengers.
And Liz Cheney is a Republican whose
politics I disagree with, who recently
said insane things about abortion. But alongside
the cast of characters running against her, she
seems completely sane and normal. Check out this
series of highlights. This looks like a Saturday
Night Live skit. It really does. But these are
the people that she's running against. Then
you'll see that when we hear from Liz Cheney kind
of sprinkled in here, she sounds completely sane
because of the people around her. Check this out.
Speaker 3: We're going to go to what we call
a lightning round.
Speaker 4: January
six was a set up from the beginning.
Or we cannot have actual. Oh, gosh.
Speaker 3: Oh, see, I'm anyway right.
Speaker 4: What we saw happen on January 6th was
clearly an attempt to delay the
count of the electoral votes.
Speaker 3: Coronavirus vaccine policy. They knew
Fauci had awards for his work inside vaccines.
Speaker 4: Mr. Fauci is one of the most
corrupt individuals in Washington DC.
We are to oppose any vaccines. Everybody ought
to get vaccinated and we need to do everything
we can to protect ourselves from future viruses.
Speaker 1: Right. Compared to the rest of them.
Liz Cheney, sound sane.
Speaker 3: Residents
faith in the election process.
Speaker 4: I understand when I
talked to Mike Lindell, he did say that there
was a small, small portion of voter fraud in
the state, but that is alarming.
Speaker 3: What about Facebook
using the system to try to
steer people? We know for a fact
all the major Internets do that. The truth.
Speaker 1: We have a number of Internets and we're
going to be looking at them very, very strongly.
Speaker 4: Thousand Rules movie is something that
I think we have great concern about.
Speaker 3: Voting machines that,
you know, our suspected fraud.
Speaker 4: There are politicians in this country
beginning with Donald Trump who have lied to the
American people. He consistently has said that
the election was stolen when it wasn't Ukraine.
Speaker 3: Ukraine is corrupt. We started it.
We got involved. We pushed them into
being against the Russian government.
Speaker 4: Money laundering. I think that's
the biggest ticket for the Ukrainians and
the Biden administration. It's the front line
in the battle for freedom. And I think we've
got to elect serious leaders, serious leader.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the Ukraine's I like that.
The only serious person on the stage is Liz
Cheney. And she's pretty nuts. I disagree
with her politics, but to some degree on
some issues, she's tethered to reality.
She went on later in the debate to point out that
her opponent, Hagaman, I forget her first name.
The things that Hagaman is saying about the
election are the exact same claims that got Rudy
Giuliani and Sidney Powell disbarred as attorneys.
Speaker 4: I think that that in Wyoming,
we have tremendously secure elections. I also know
that the truth matters and the claims that Mrs.
Hagaman is making about the 2020 election are the
same claims for which the president's lead lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani, was disbarred. True, they are the
same claims for which Sidney Powell has had her
law license suspended. Right. They are simply not
true. It is not true that there was sufficient
fraud to change the results of the. On May 20
election. The president's own attorney general
has said that the president's own deputy attorney
general has said that. And I mean, President
Trump, President Trump's campaign manager, said
that President Trump's White House counsel said
that President Trump's own family. All right.
Speaker 1: So you get it. She sounds completely
sane. And yet just 12 hours ago, Liz Cheney
made some wild claims about Democrats
murdering babies. She's nuts, but she's a lot
less nuts than the people on the stage with her.
It is a it is it it's a circling the drain of
sorts that we have. It's a race to the bottom.
Speaker 4: And that's to make sure
that every American understands
what today's Democrat Party stands for with
respect to babies and with respect to the murder
of babies. We have seen now in states across
the country the introduction of legislation
that would enable the killing of babies.
This is not about abortion. This is
about killing babies after they are born.
Speaker 1: She is also bonkers. But look at
the people running against her. This does not
bode well for the country. That debate looked
almost like it would be a skit. I don't I don't
actually know. Like that lightning round thing
is so cartoonish. If Saturday Night Live wants to
do a parody of it, if they want to satirize it,
how do they do it? I'm not even sure
they can because it's a parody of itself.
And who whoever wins in that race, it's
bad. Liz Cheney, I guess, is sort of like
marginally less bad. And that's about that. That's
the most positive spin I can possibly put on it.